(swoosh)
- Step one is obsess, get totally focused,
unleash your desire,
that gives the energy.
Step two is not waiting.
It's massive action, keep
changing your approach
until you find effective execution.
If you're running east
looking for a sunset,
I don't care how positive you are,
you're not going to see the sunset.
It's the wrong strategy.
- Not going to happen.
- It's just not going to happen.
So you got to have a proven strategy,
and you can get there faster,
same way I've done it with these books,
just saying, "I could go this,
"or I could spend four years,
"interview 50 of the
smartest people in the world,
"all billionaires that
started with nothing
"and find out what they did,
"and compress decades into days."
That's really the purpose
of everything that I do.
So when you have that plan
and you keep changing your approach,
I always tell people,
"How long would you give your average kid
"to learn how to walk
"before you turned to the kid and said,
"Dude, it's never going to happen.
"You're not a walker.
"Just give it up."
People are like, "Are you crazy?
"My kid is going to keep trying until."
Well that's really step two.
You keep changing your
approach until you find it.
And then the third step to achievement
really is, simple as it may sound,
if you're obsessed,
you know what you want,
you're taking massive action,
maybe you modeled somebody to
figure out the right action
so you get there quicker,
and you're executing,
you still need a little grace.
Some people call it luck,
you could call it God,
but I really believe that
there's the part we do
and then there's the
part that comes to us,
but I do know grace shows up a lot more
when you do the first
two steps on your own,
and grace shows up a lot more
when you acknowledge grace in your life,
when you acknowledge that
I was born in a world
where I didn't have to build this internet
that I can pull out of my pocket
the answer to everything on Earth.
I'm driving on streets I didn't pave.
I'm reading books I didn't have to write.
That's the gift of our lives,
and I think when we experience that grace,
we don't just experience more achievement,
but we start to experience
more fulfillment.
- And grace not only effects
your ability to get there,
but it effects what
you do and how you live
once you are there.
- It really determines
the quality of your life,
because unless you live
in a state of gratitude...
I did an interview with
Sir John Templeton,
who as you know is one of the
first billionaire investors
and just a brilliant man.
He came from nothing,
and he donated, I think it was 750,
they still do it, The Templeton Fund,
I think it's 750 million dollars a year,
it's bigger than the Nobel
Fund that he donates,
and one day I asked him, I said,
"What is the secret to wealth?"
And he looked at me, paused,
this big smile and his
eyes got really bright
like they always did, and he said,
"Tony, it's what you teach."
And I said, "Well, I teach a
lot of things, which thing?"
- He said, "Gratitude."
He said, "Because you and I Tony
"know billionaires that are miserable,
"and it's because they're not
grateful for what they have.
"And we both know people
who have no money seemingly,
"but they're so grateful for their health,
"for their husband, for their
wife, for their children,
"they're so grateful to God,
"they're so grateful for
their life that they're rich."
So I think it starts with that gratitude.
It starts with that connection to grace
as simplistic as that sounds.
So it's not enough just to
have your financial plan.
You can have all the
money and be miserable.
Let's have the money and
be really rich emotionally,
psychologically and spiritually.4
(swoosh)